[Music]
the northeast of England we will call at
Darlington Durham this wants labor land
until brexit and Boris Johnson changed
all that I've come to stop and to see
whether labor could be on track to win
their heartlands back this week's local
elections a dry run for the big general
election likely next year
at this launch community club in
Stockton wait what is nothing changes
yeah they're not yet convinced by anyone
obviously you hear all these things are
going to do this they're going to do
that and nothing ever happens it doesn't
change so you just feel really
disillusioned yeah yeah
these voters cynical but amongst them
one issue is dominant you constantly
looking to see how much you've got left
on that meeting yeah and that can drain
you can't it what I normally have is
about 60 pounds left to get food and
drink in the house but part of what
Boris Johnson talked about in 2019 they
promised to let you know
nothing's changed nothing's changed it's
it's been harder
the economy is showing small signs of
recovery but people here not feeling it
and what do you think of the labor party
understand that do you think they might
help people more you don't no no do you
like his Starman do you I do think
he's better than any other times could
possibly do and I will admit that I
don't think he's like the standard so
what what countries need him but I think
he's right in the middle basically for
me it's whoever will be able to lower
the cost of living it's I think it's
it's terrible right now do you think his
storm will do it
um there's got to be a change whatever I
asked to be a change a government it's
not working for 13 years has she seen
that what do you think of him I prefer
Boris but I like Boris it was like it
was man he was one like you know Johnson
wants a vote winner in these parts but
he's now gone and labor a battle into
win voters here back and regain control
of Stockton Council this is a key local
election Battleground and it's smaller
fights like this up and down the country
that tell the story of a bigger War the
battle for 2024 so these elections are a
big deal what are we looking for can
starmus show that he's still on course
to beat the conservatives next year can
sunac put in a strong set of results and
give the conservatives a Slither of hope
I'm looking more towards sort of an
independent
um I've lost confidence in the
conservative party I don't feel they've
done enough us as a working a working
people
I don't really have confidence in labor
I don't feel Care staff is a strong
enough leader I like Boris Johnson I
thought you've done a good job
even also fond of the past PM is
sticking with the party for now would
you vote for Rishi next time or will she
soon out
um
he hasn't really had a fair chance at
the minute whoever gets into they're
going to get a rough deal anywhere you
know but personally I think he's doing
okay and I would vote for him yeah I
would how votes trade this week tell him
for next year's much bigger test the
battle has begun ahead of next year's
all-out War Beth Rigby Sky News in
Stockton